I'm testing. Wait, I forgot to put something on my head.
Test, test, test, test.
Hold on.
Can you hear me testing? Testing, this is my Google.
Are you ready for the ASMR?
Are you?
Oh, no, don't make me smile.
Oh, I hear myself.
Hold on.
Okay, there we go. Hello, can you hear me?
Ah, ah, Mike, okay.
Okay.
If you just make me jump a bit bigger.
Hold on, let me make you a tiny bit bigger.
I need you slightly larger. Hello.
It's supposed to be ASMR, but please, let's just all examine this.
Oh, sorry, this is a real ASMR, so do not listen to ASMR volumes.
Or you will cause yourself, and this thing is called, tonight is, yeah, done.
Don't lose yourself to the night.
There we go.
Yes, that wifling is literally you.
Okay, and then we put, I swiped on, and then I think I'm ready to strap in.
I just, I don't know what's gonna happen when we get to the shower bar.
Because putting the shower on is gonna be something else.
It's gonna be so fucking loud.
Okay, I'm ready to work out, I don't know.
This one's good.
It's good to pick it up.
Okay.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
Are we ready?
Was that too loud?
Tell me if I need to turn up the ASMR, okay?
Like, if I need to turn up the microphone, because last night when I was blown out, and then this time, it looks like it's too quiet.
The real ASMR, by the way, is cus cus cus cus cus, real ASMR.
It's quiet, okay, hold on.
Hello.
This is a microphone test.
I put the sound up a bit.
Microphone test, oh my god, it's vibrant.
We can, like, do it like this.
It's still too quiet, right?
Okay, strap.
As you know, I need to use, I love this strap.
So, if you want to hear this ASMR sound,
this is what's called medical tape,
and I'm gonna use this cus cus cus cus cus to attach the band or the joy gone to my leg, okay?
Try talking normal, see if it's still quiet.
Is it too quiet?
I mean, I'm about to start hopping and puffing.
Cus cus cus cus.
The sister's ASMR.
Is it still too quiet?
Jeez.
I turn up the volume just a little bit more, okay?
Cus cus cus cus cus.
So the heart rate plus weight is broken right now.
We're just gonna have to take the L and C in my heart rate.
You're just gonna have to trust with my breathing.
I'm actually just a little nervous.
Do you want me to mute the game more?
Are you okay with the kind of being in the background?
It's a bit of a boom.
This ASMR, this is real ASMR, by the way.
I hope you don't overexert yourself.
That's my hidden speciality.
I give everything my all.
Okay, so on the tie,
let's strap it in.
That maybe should have done more tape.
Oh, I should have done way more tape.
Hold on.
Okay.
This is gonna fall off so quickly.
I'm gonna tell them that.
No, not okay.
Not okay.
I'm not done yet.
Slow down.
Ring fat.
I've not even secured it.
You've been a bit too quick for me.
You've been a bit too quick.
Ring fat.
This game is exciting for me to exercise.
I was more excited the game were the right brief ones.
But thank you so much for doing this and subscribers.
My tracking is gonna get lost.
Oh, that's me celebrating that.
It's still...
I forgot the word.
Do you hear those?
I'm taking the tape off.
At the back of it.
I don't know how loud the shower's gonna be.
It's gonna be ridiculously loud.
Okay, there we go.
I am now double strapped up.
It is time for the reckoning.
Slight the joy-con
into the ring for the accessory.
Why, yes, of course.
I know how to do that.
Like this.
Sksksks.
Oh, yeah.
Press on the ring.
Okay.
There's a microphone.
Hi, Mr. Microphone.
It's right in front of me,
so I can get around your ears really easily.
But this is...
We can stand a little bit.
Okay.
Oh my god, you can see.
It's me.
Can you see me wiggling my butt?
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
You see me twerking there?
Oh, I don't have my collar on.
Hold on.
Call her ASMR.
Are you ready for this?
Do you hear this?
Hold on.
Is it too loud?
Is the collar too loud?
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
A reflin just asked if I was naked.
What the fuck?
No.
I'm not naked.
What the fuck?
Why would I be naked?
I'm wearing an accessory.
Okay.
I think I was lost.
ASMR, by the way.
ASMR.
Okay.
Move cars there.
Up and down.
Got it.
Adult should be supervised by reflinks.
Okay.
We'll do quick play again.
Because I can't hear any of the in-game audio
because my headset doesn't work.
We're gonna do all the booty.
ASMR.
Is there a clue?
Come on, give us a clue.
ASMR.
Show us what we know.
Lower body, ears.
Crashing.
Okay.
Just as a warning.
I'm gonna, the track, it's gonna die
like every two seconds, but
in exchange you get audio.
So, I don't know.
There were scoots in the beginning.
Did I miss that?
Okay, let's go.
Start on the floor and bend your knees.
Hold the ringcon between your thighs.
Squeeze your knees together.
Oh, no.
Okay.
First things first, I'm on the floor
with the collar on.
Okay.
Squeeze it in between your thighs.
Bro, my fan is out.
Okay, let's go.
I can't hear anything.
It just launched across the room.
I didn't have a good enough hold on my thighs.
Okay.
Did you hear it fly across the room?
What is that?
You don't need to scream for the exercise.
Watch below.
Okay.
Spread your feet wide.
Bend your hips and lean forward.
This is very unpar for what I'm wearing.
Hold it horizontal.
Oh, my chair is in the way.
What is that?
Am I to squat?
Oh, I'm to squat.
It's Mars.
Fucking hell that thing's vibing.
It sounds like something else.
I don't even need to think about it.
Okay.
Okay, here I come.
Stand with your feet.
Far.
Raise both arms.
Okay.
What?
Excuse me.
Oh, I'm not ready for this.
Did I get one exam?
Oh.
Raise more by the way.
Oh, I better think of this one.
Watch right now.
Okay.
Dissxxtxtxtxtxt.
Like how my heart is going.
Spread your feet and get your toes parallel.
Scalp.
Bro, my heart is going.
Breathe.
From my nose.
Okay.
I don't breathe through my nose though.
eeeeeee
okay
what the fuck
okay, i can tell
im actually not too bad at that
okay, uff, you know
I'm not breathing through my nose, stop telling me to breathe through my nose
There's so many tickles, it can feel like I'm going to be back
And there's a little further back
Ten of us stop and
Mother day
Band a little more
I'm working for it
I'm working for a whole straight line of yet
Finish
Let's go
Can't see it, I'm twerking
Average score, bing
Okay, finish
And let me take a sip of water
Okay, hydration ASMR
Oh my god, when I lean forward the collar presses against my throat
It's actually not that comfortable
Hydration
Why does my throat smell like that?
That was so loud
I don't want to slurp
ASMR, ASMR, ASMR
Are you jangling?
Do you want to hear that tapping with my cough?
Or do you want to hear the tapping of it?
That's the joy-con strap
I'm raising my legs so you can hear it
Are you jangling?
You better be
No, it's not uncomfortable, actually, forget the collars
They're all leaning forward
Okay, what's that?
What's that? We'll do a glistening ASMR for a second
Okay, glistening ASMR
You're going to get shower ASMR shortly
Please, glitz, focus
That's what I'll be waiting for
Let's see that slate
Here we go
Glitz over squalled it
Oh, no
Okay, what's that?
Right there, there we go
Okay, let's go
This will focus on working your way
Good job
Amazing
Great
You're making me cry again
I need to turn off the camcorder
Yes, right now
Amazing
Okay, what's that?
Game sound?
Raise both arms
Just keep it in, it's fine, okay
Game sound is good
Okay, copy cam
Oh, no, no
ASMR tickles
Relaxation
Sleep
Oh my god, my eyes just clapped
Did you hear that? My eyes just clapped
Did you hear that?
I don't know why
I'm too embarrassed after that
I don't know
It was hard
It's more
Sleep, relaxation, de-stress
I can't believe it
Oh my god
Tentacle
Thank you, Jason
I'm gonna stop taking screenshots
Oh no, not again, this might happen across the room
These guys are your knees together
I'm trying
This is so weird for my people
Because I'm so aware that I have a color
Okay
You're falling asleep
And you're enjoying the breathy whisper tangle ASMR
And soon you will find yourself relaxed
Oh no
Oh, I know
Okay, ready, tingle
Okay, we're tingling
Okay
Okay, copy
Runners
Okay
And you're tingling
To the sound of me trying to runners
On the floor
This is the color of fucking chalks, yeah
I'm looking
Oh my god, you can
Can you hear my ass again?
Okay
Ready
Okay, I'm up
Tangle's a lot there, don't know about you
I've got an A
I don't know how I'm doing so well
Okay
Do you wanna hear mommy's heartbeat?
This is all for you
Can you hear it?
Hey
How are you?
How's Johnny?
Johnny, why don't you record your heartbeat ASMR?
Because that's my resting heart rate, okay?
That's what my resting heart rate is
Okay, as you should then
I'll read all of the things at the end, okay?
Thank you
My dream
Do it my hips way
You don't need to see my full model all the time
My dream
In the middle of a gym
An ASMRist approaches you and cleans your ears
Tangle, tangle, tangle, tangle
Can you hear me?
Tangle, tangle
Let me clean those ears of yours
Yes, clean, clean, clean
But what about your other ears?
Is this one dirty too?
Your heartbeat sounds like a rave
Yeah, you're like
You're not clean
Tangle
Okay
Let me do a heartbeat check
Okay, let's just check that my heartbeat's gone down a little
I think it's gone down
Do I need to take a drink that would replace
the salt I lose from my sweat?
That's why you're here rave-ling
You're my after-work out silly
Okay, let's go again
We'll challenge ourselves
We'll do a 10
But I'm new
D1
Do you want to make me sweat rave-ling?
Do you want to watch me sweat?
Okay
We'll do the ear-rolling set
Okay, we'll work on this one
Okay, let's go
Oh shit, I have to focus now
Let's just lay down this time real short
Okay
Okay, I have to do that heartbeat
Check, check, check, check
Oh, sorry
I don't really seem like much
I want to do it in front of you
4, 5, 6, 7, 6, 7, 8, 9, 9, 10
Barrel!
Dumb
Hard over there
I'm breaking up and I'm sweating
Oh I'mVIbe soaking
is not being done
Oh my Al
Really
How start
Sorry
I'm sorry, I think my fit's coming up again, I think my fit's coming up, oopsies, ASMRs, tingle, tingle, okay it's down, raise both arms, okay
you're falling asleep, we've got my eyes closed in this fucking way, stop, brah
it keeps doing it in this one, I expressed my excuse that I couldn't do it
sksk sksk sksk
oh brah
I feel very exposed in this one
I don't have a particular reason
you know what I mean, I'm useful
am I fighting me? you know, I'm wearing a collar
mommy you school, I'll check under you
I'll prove to you that I'm wearing something, see, you hear that, that's the name, that's my name on my neck
I don't know why, I don't know why you think I'm unique
hydration day, honestly it's just really strange, I don't know why
that exercise keeps making me calm
mom?
you and the bird's eye view of mommy working out, you're so funny
I mean, I could put your collar on too
I got a collar for you as well, see, this one says refling, R-E-E-F-L-I-N-G
and I can put it on you right now if you want
I'm supposed to be collar
let me put it on you
hold on, I'll put it on you, you're ready
okay, I just need to loop a bit, I suck at this part
hold still
mommy said hold still
okay, your collar's on, you look perfect
and you're like extra adorable with your collar on
are you ready?
any chance for a bail or some jangling?
I don't have a bail
okay, we go again, we do a new one
now that you're in the break of a sweat
do you look good in the collar?
you look adorable
come here, give me a hug
you look so precious in that collar
I think we look really cute together
do you like getting hugs on with me, huh?
yeah, I bet you do
okay, you're funny like that refling right now
well, you don't want a sweaty hug so much
maybe the weird gym girls come up to you and give you ASMRs
what else can I do to you?
to annoy you at the gym?
are you feeling a little too hot?
do you need some water?
there you go
that should kill you then
are you feeling all nice and refreshed?
hey
all refreshed
open your mouth
I'll hydrate you
yeah
I'll read all of the ends, I promise, okay?
I want it
okay, one more little bit of hydration
oh no, don't accidentally southern me when I'm trying to bend
skks
okay
now that you're all dangled and ready to go for the next one
okay, I don't want abs
legs
did I do legs?
posture
when we do legs
did I do them?
oh, I can't remember
did I do legs?
stamina
for working your stamina?
you want me to do posture, okay?
I promise I'll get the correct posture for you one day, daddy
you guys are a bit archer back
posture, oh my god, what the fuck was that preview?
bro, pose the ASMR, what was that?
what was that?
okay, ASMR
good morning
sorry
ASMR
I'm sorry for making you feel bad
hi, ma'am, I'm so sorry
thank you for 20k, thank you, ma'am
I promise I'll send you that ASMR script very shortly
thank you, thank you, thank you
thank you
hold the ring up behind me
skks
oh no, I can't do any arm stuff
I can't do arm stuff
I can't do it
I can't do arm stuff at all
okay
what?
posture
wait, why am I pointing so low? I'm doing it right
I'm doing it right
and it's GM
3, 4 and it's GM
it's not right to stare at my point
okay
oh, okay
oh, there we go
what?
okay
that was 3 here
you saw this game?
okay, what's this one?
don't think it won't work
oh, you can do that one
I'm not getting it, please, no more of this one
no more of this one
every time I look down, it looks so weird
this one
I wonder how much I can do the splits
I can't really show you, you know
do you want a watermelon stream?
I thought I'd be doing a break in a watermelon
with my thigh stream
maybe for like
35k
I was gonna do 25k
as the tanker stream
and then 30k
as the Rebecca Cyberpunk stream
so on 35k
we could combine our forces
and fuck up some fruit
that one didn't make my heart sweat as much
can you hear that?
I don't really feel like it made me
work up that much of a sweat
should I do a full arm one?
oh, you want me to paint a reef one
on the marsh and the watermelon?
it's actually pretty smart, I might do that
that's a really good idea
thank you for giving me stream ideas
so I don't have to think all the time
stamina?
well
I need more stamina to make sure
I keep having fun with you, I don't know
start with a tomato
do loads of fruit and I'll paint you on all the fruit
nooooo
I regret my choice already
reefing on my hands and knees where I belong
no, not another one please
sit on the floor and raise your legs
oh no
oh dear
there's only this
excuse me?
oh my god
I'm spreading
10 more
this looks ridiculous
I look like a beach whale
ok, this is giving me a bit more of a
I think
ok
raise both arms, coffee
yes
oh my god, do this
I swear I heard that club
you better stop
ok
ok, I can do this
we'll take a little rest after this one
another
oh my god
really said split
I said open up bitch
ok, I'm really gonna work even this one
oh no
stop
no
I can't
go in
he's going
ok
mommy's getting tired
I'm getting my head done
a little bit
oh
mommy definitely
fell that one
I fell that one a bit more
than the other one
the other ones are dead
I'm harboring though
ok
let me sit down for a little
a small second
ok, we'll do some
really ASMR
we'll do some more things to have for him
let me take a little drink of water first
water first
pardon me
excuse me
thank you for your ink
I need to replace my electrolytes
ok
let me just annoy you
while you're trying to do your personal things
not the gym
you see I have this new squishy toy
that can squish right on your ear
make you enjoy the tingle
tingle, tingle, tingle
good story for a free shift
they actually are doing nothing
wow, I didn't make that noise
squishy squishy squishy
security, there's a lady that's
doing things right here
can you provide us with a private room
I went to creep on mommy at the gym
I would just be on the stair
master thing where you woke up stairs
I'm gonna do those ones
I like those ones
I want a big fat booty
will ASMR kill this
tingle, tingle, tingle
walk into the gym and know you can hear us
clap, clap, clap
it won't stop
I'm like that can you put something more
not just the collar
cause it won't stop
well it's a tap in ASMR
I'll do a tap in ASMR
and as there is keychain
tt is tapping ASMR
tap tap tap tap tap tap tap
tap tap tap
I wish I was mommy's floor
well I just had to over you
before stream started
and I didn't over it since the last time
I couldn't ring this since it's been a while
I need to clean your ears again a little bit
click, click
oh are you cutting some off
I'm gonna clean the fuck out of your disgusting ass
here's your bum
okay I'm ready for more
do you think you can add no more of me working out
it's shower time sin
I'm sorry that was my bowl
okay
you don't want to reduce the gains while wearing clothes
wait
do you guys have a really good imagination
of how to scrape something to ya
check for chafing on the collar
I don't feel any
it feels nice
okay
I'm currently wearing a collar
and I'm gonna put one knee up on my chair
to push it to the side of the room
that's all
do it that way you will
let's see
what else
flexibility
I need to be flexible
wait did we do a flexibility
I'm not sure
maybe
then I can't stand up at work
you're at work listening to this
keep going
no go for flexibility
flexible
ASMR tingles
tingle, tingle, tingle
I'll check everything out
the industry
oh no
does it know
why would it put me in that position
I think it knows
I hate scaring the one
it's the fact that
I'm facing you as well
that makes it even
louder
oh
oh no
wait
we just do bend one way
bend your right knee
I know that's what I do when I sit on my chair
I think it knows
okay it's more those
go
you can go
don't be scared
don't be shy
oh yuck
ee
okay
where am I
I'm to hold it
switching sides
okay
lower me
hold it
okay
I'm sorry
forgive me
I'm a shroop
I'm getting showered
I'm just trying to fucking show
this one isn't that hard
there's no hard exercise
I feel like we need to do a really hard one
put your left foot forward
and your right foot behind
bend your
forward leg and squat
squatting
I like squatting
go
oh listen
oh no this isn't squatting
brace through your nose
I can't breathe
okay no we're not doing this one again
we're doing like
freaking
I just jumped into the next pose
and I accepted it right away
we'll end it on a really hard one
okay and then we'll go first
I will deal
with this
put your left leg forward and your right back
and put it above my head
okay
no arm ones please it kills me
will we do another butt one
I hate these
me
I get as good for your flexibility
switch sides
I did it in one jump
I'm just asking
this is just called breathing
what the fuck is that
you won't need this screen
is that a joke
what is that
spread your feet wide
hold it behind my back
puff out your chest
I'm a man
oh fuck
well excuse me
god damn
in my collar
I'm fucking bending over
hello
oh my really
fucking turn behind there
I hate it
I don't get it
I didn't expect that one
that was my score
that it
bruh I do you
I don't really
I don't really feel too tired
I can only hear my heart we check
you're my heartbeat
I don't really feel that right to be
for Betty and Lesha
still the beginner
I just positioned myself behind
what
bent over hands behind her back
wait a minute I've been here before
hey it's like that
one artwork
that's under the smoke fish tank
what one should we do
you pick
Evelyn pick what one you want
I don't know what one to do
no arms
fuck arms
you want stamina
we can do stamina
okay for stamina
there
I'll read all the super chats at the end
okay we're doing hardcore
we're going out with a bang
let me sip some more
then we're gonna go to the shower next
there's a wrestling match
between me and the girls
why
I mean I'd fucking win
but why
why are we fighting
what we're fighting over the refund
shit I'd win in a heartbeat the fuck
in me I know for a fact
is a weakling
she be is a weakling
I say is a fucking weakling
I could throw up in the air for fun
as a weakling
I win
are you not in your fucking teeth
I win nothing
I'm probably stronger faster
than all the girls sorry I said it
I said how it is I don't care
I'm winning I don't care if I'm a weakling on the arms
my legs gonna clutch
my legs are gonna clutch
nothing goes in the way
she be knows
you'd get clapped
no she'd get clapped with my fucking cheeks
we're gonna have a close each
she be
okay this is hardcore
we're not fucking around here
I'm here to get fit
I'm here to get fit okay
this pup is here for some fucking fun
can you register
well let me arch my back
why are you not registering
which room
okay this is hardcore
oh please don't clap
no
stop it
this is supposed to be an ASMR stream
is it done
I can't see
I'm a bit tired
it is said
for hardcore
what is the idea
there's a whizzy knife
what am I doing
sit on the floor and raise your legs
okay mommy's so even tired
no mommy's just a little bit tired
that's all
I'm fucking
the implication of hardcore
means there's filthy casual
why are my hardcore
I can't
I can't do it
I can't fucking do it
if I clap I clap
I can't accept my fate
oh my god
sorry
I can't
hello
hello Bray
I want you to know
I'm giving them all
that's my heart
I don't know if you can even hear
oh
okay
two more stop taking screenshots
two more
okay
put me in
put me back in
I can take it
yeah I'd like to see
my gen mates doing this
okay
okay one more
one more
okay
I can do it
here you go
if I need to look
and you just bend that one
and now I'm trying so hard
I'm trying really hard
to hold it together for you
one more
you want me to squat on it
oh fuck it just hit my head
I just hit my head
I can't keep it together
oh
I'm on the floor
I can't take any more
you want me for it
oh
you win
I submit
what was my score
I don't need
that's good
this is
my new home to have the floor
I belong on the floor
yeah
I'd like to see my gen mates do that
you come to me
and you tell me you think
any of them are stronger than me
get it tae folk
oh
oh my god
my fanny is glistening my sweat
okay I'm up
I'm up
okay it's mine
okay I'm up
okay I'm just
coming over to the chair
okay I'm at the chair
hello
thank you for watching
oh what the fuck are you giving me mine
I'm gonna have to take the cold roll
for the shower
I'm sorry I don't want it to get wet
it's already covered in sweat
I was actually not that bad like covered in sweat
I'm so stressed
Alicia
let me get my breasts back
and then we'll catch up and we'll do a shower okay
damn right
is your head okay
yeah I hit the
sorry ASMR I hit the
joycoat on my head
like point blank
imagine the smell
why imagine I want to go to sleep
on your face
ASMR
okay thank you so much
call group for the 50 gifted memberships
thank you reluctantly
say for the 10 gifted
thank you Dynan Tim
10 quid mutial
I haven't asked Dynan for too long
for the 10 gifted memberships
thank you Cossillionaire
for the 20 gifted
million ships memberships
thank you Mass
for the 50 gifted memberships
thank you so much ASMR
thank you
ale vivas
for the 10 gifted memberships guys
oh my god refluence
Oden Yakuchi
thank you for the 10 gifted oh my god
stepuichi
too thank you for the membership
lord of storms
thank you for the super chat
the world wouldn't
be able to handle ring fit
collab I'm already on it
oh my god refluence
I'm gonna throw up
thank you
the baby lord for the 10 gifted
thank you Eiko
for the 10 gifted
oh my god
reflinks
reflinks has too much
salsa for us thank you for the 20 gifted memberships
oh my god
bro you're breaking it
it's it's struggling to assign people
thank you for all the gifted memberships
refers
thank you for the gifted membership
I'm afraid I'm winning
if it comes to physical
fate I'm winning
max bros
thank you for the extended membership
thank you the baby lord
for the super chat
thanks to my husband
so
thank you lord of storms for the super chat
you won an after work
picture I have a picture on the way
in two days time for my alternative
to ever
I've lost gals
to this stream
didn't Kira no react to that
and she says I hope you find it
Kira is such a legend
sleepy phoenix thank you for the super chat
basically with
my tip
might not be relaxed but that's definitely thank you
mommy got a natural clap
we're a true friend of uploss
thank you my queen right there
anonymous being at the gym right now
sweaty and I'm afraid listening to this
might be the causes of going to
thanks for getting me close
I got you close
Jason thank you for this
super chat
strongy was strongy's favorite number
thank you
of this
you'll be funded gen 4 bro
gen 3 funds are already fucking getting started
and the rate you guys are giving them
is so far too generous
thank you everyone
the baby lord wall I would like to be a
fly on the wall one night
thank you so so much
basically was
if I weren't waiting for your next picture
I'm a little lost so much pink
oh you might be waiting another day
more chance
more VR
has any of my gen mates done a
rank fit stream yet
I'll need to add them on my switch
and then beat all their scores
that's my only motivation in rank fit
add my gen mates and beat all
of their scores
whatever their scores I'm gonna beat it
oh hydration
okay I am going to
mute the game audio
or the desktop audio cause we are now
going to go for a shower okay
now this is gonna get loud
I don't know
I don't know how to do this
all I know is it's gonna get loud cause I need to
now move you
into the bathroom okay
so please lower your volume
strongy challenge
or your gen mates to finish or I need to take off
the dry comb sorry do you want to
listen to me peel off the medical tape
open my thigh
that's all the moment juicy thigh
but wait there's more
open my open my leg
run the mic okay
it's on the desk
sorry
yes I use medical tape cause I lost my strap
thank you anonymous boston rena
thank you mommy
three two one go
oh zero sorry zero
it's supposed to be zero
okay thank you anonymous
slice saver
you can give this material
when I'm on vacation in kenwick
he's strong
okay
everyone lower your volume
I'm not bringing you into the shower
okay
if you hear kimmy and fico
just ignore them
they're gonna be meowing at me
okay let's go for
a very oh wait hold on
sorry
let me just show you what I prepared for the shower
portion of the stream
no
for the next roughly 10 minutes
will I go for a shower
I'm not able to reach out
okay
but I will be fine
surely
you can't say I don't put effort into my streams
I shall not tolerate that slander
come on we're going to the bathroom
I need to open up the bathroom
oh sorry
sorry
I hope you didn't hear that
let me just show you the door
okay I've got back to ASMR
I'm gonna go lower
artificially lower the ASMR microphone
just by a couple of days of hours
do not be at too high
I'm gonna go for a walk
but very gently so I don't build on my cables
okay walkies
oh my god the wires are built
look at the wires
come on please think about the wires
those are
ASMR
okay you're now in the bathroom
I'm gonna put you right here
can you tell me in the bathroom
okay I'm just gonna follow the wires
okay
the reason
you can tell in the bathroom's book
is because this change should also
look
this is my towel
do you hear it
I'm just gonna very quickly
go through and check the audio
so I'm not trying to show everyone
so just give me a moment
okay this is gonna be very loud
so what I'm gonna do
I don't know if you can even hear me over the water
what I am
I'm gonna do is jump in the shower
really quickly
this is too loud
I don't want you to make it quieter
I'm trying
I need to bring the microphone closer
to me
I'm so sorry
I'm in the shower now
oh
I love you daddy
okay I'm under the water
it is behind by the way
I know that this is so funny
in all of my practices
so
what are you doing
like showers like at the gym
you get to see the shower
if I go, wait that's not going down to the water
can you hear my background come under the water lately
my head is sticking out of the shower
talking to you right now
okay
I think I'll do it
I'm gonna spend the whole night with it
on my butt
and on my toes
oh I just have a hand on the glass
oh
I didn't know but
thanks mom
hi
can you hear me again
did you hear any of that
oops I love super mom
but
that's just a little bit of soup
that's not gonna hurt anyone
okay
I have no idea if I live there
but yes I did just take a shower
okay
I now have a towel
I'm gonna dry you off first
okay it's warm
okay
I'm dryin' my face
I'm gonna make too much soap
I'm having to use
oh my god do you hear the sad story
I'm having to use dub for body soap
cause my skin's been rubbish recently
I can't use my lemon soap right now
I'm having to use dub
for sensitive skin
ASMR
okay so I'm gonna do it once I'm dry
I'm gonna apply deodorant
and then I'm gonna sit back
and we'll pretend to do ASMR
okay
oh there's a scale
oh I'll weigh myself
let's see if I put on any weights
oh shit
let's see how heavy I am
kilograms
oh lost weight
I don't know what this is
49.95 kilograms technically
I've lost weight right now
okay
and then I will bring you back into
my stream
right now
was it really somewhere or was that just like
okay I can see, I can read chat now
hi chat, hi nicklinks
I know
I guess she's wasting all of it
no don't start crying
I forgot to do deodorant
hold on I forgot to do deodorant
oh
hi
I'll put on maybe
mommy avatar
mommy youtuber
did you understand
like anything I said in the shower
if only drops a mic I'm gonna
can we dry you, you wanna dry me
you could hear me that
oh
not one word
okay there's a bit of a contrast going on
I'll change the screen hold on
I'm putting deodorant on here
see this is Roland deodorant
I'm gonna put it on like this
I normally use like a
put it on like a stick
but I'm out of deodorant
I'm out of soap, I'm out of everything
because I'm not being looking after myself
deodorant yes I'm not
fucking fair I'm on max and after that
oh
sorry I just cut it in there
no that's my heart right
okay that's me
do not zoom into that
okay look how do I hide the background
no that's me
hi
you want some ASMR
we'll pretend to do ASMR
I'm too strong
imagine if I'll stop
actually when I close my door I'm surprised
am I putting
okay I'm gonna turn out my microphone a little bit
so don't be startled
hi Roland
do you want me to put my collar back on
do you want another cuddle
so this is my heart beating now
okay this is my heart beating
hold on
there you go
so that's my current heartbeat
okay let me put my
my collar back on
I thought I was sweating a lot more on it
but there's not really anything on it
that says I was sweating
I wonder if it was just because
it was on my neck at a specific point
why does it sound like it's beating faster
it might just be my heart
I do have a heart thingy
but don't panic
don't zoom
my heart's doing things on all directions
okay
that's our collar on
okay I'm neck up my blankie
I get my ASMR tools
oh I need to take your collar off
you still have your collar on
I don't know if I need to take yours off yet
cause I don't
I'm gonna get some ASMR tools
my tools that I'm wearing
she's all washed and ready for a treat
no you wanna leave that one
okay we both collared
okay I'm gonna pretend to do ASMR now
let me make sure I redirected this to you
later
cause I'll forget if I don't do it now
okay I'm gonna do a little role play
but I hope you enjoyed being at the gym with me
even though that was a very very
excessive gym
that gym was very difficult
okay I'm sorry about all the mouse clicking
a shock collar
no I'm not wearing my shock collar today
I'm wearing my collar
that I got for being a good pup
and I also got your collar as well
so
those claps were great bro
they were so embarrassing
my pup wouldn't stop
okay
oh is she being on speaker?
don't lay out
this collar is much more fun
yeah I'm a bit biased
okay clean your ears
so how long have you been going to the gym for?
don't worry I just started as well
I'm somewhat of a novice
but I'm sure you can teach me a few things
you see
oh it's been struggling
what are you gonna do with the fog?
leave it up, I'm doing exercise
you're allowed to breathe while exercising
that's why we're doing ring fit
naturally
just for poseable tonight
I need to work on my
flex ability
to struggle
with my back
flex ability
it's rather difficult
for me to arch it
so you know
you should definitely
help me
to work out
oh then you're true to go to your games
average game in session
where the pros think they're cool
hold on let me just
move my level
my calibration
do my calibration
alright
I agree to it
my calibration is more
okay there we go
it sees me a lot better
I don't know where to put this off
I can hear it the best way
all your games
bro that one move
it can give me the same move
over and over
you clapped about 40 times during the work
did I actually?
so I could hear it
when it was really loud
but I stayed up all night just to watch the stream
I'm so sorry for you some schedule
you clapped a wall
I don't know
I thought it was like once or twice
during that one
exercise
in particular
just with the song
thank you
day and night
we're going back
we're working out hard
so only
the only thing to remedy
is being a long, hard worker
is ear cupping
thank you
and our
dark work coming in
the runners are better
claim are such a cool
the reef link thing in the rake oil
we gave ourselves a stand
I mean I could still do it right now
when I've been
when I've been about puppy
you have to put me in the corner
and tell me to clap
the egg
clamors and the echo
don't sure I should have been renamed to random
the laughter of the clap
the bearer of this love
I've done cataclysmic clothing
basically oh you've been a bad puppy
go into the corner of the room
and think about it
think about what you've done
I mean wait
can I do something really silly
can I go into the kitchen and clap
and see if you can hear
I like the free edge
okay right
just this is a test
okay this is just a test
I'm gonna go into the kitchen
and see if you can hear this
when I'm up
did you hear that
did you
okay
it was weird
it's like thunder
it was me in my kitchen
like a cookie
okay
yeah
clap clap clap
exercise
no no do it again
sit on the mic
I can I'm gonna break it
this is my expensive mic
so if you didn't know
3DO the brand of microphone
or mostly known for ASMR
they released a microphone
they released a black one
and a white one
and the white one is 500
and the black one is 2000
and I was like oh I want to
on my ASMR game
I'm gonna buy the black one
and it like sounds no different
and I used the black one
for my role plays
but I have to use it right now
for when I do ASMR
and shower
or bath night stuff
and there is like
like
everyone in chat
going feral, good
I like it that way
we can be feral for each other
but on ASMR too
I've got a fluffy
you can hear the fluffy
over your ear
it sounds like a perverable
well people were asking
would I ever give a KU
microphone
now I would love to
but I don't think I even
have the capabilities
to utilize it properly
like if I was up in my game
to a KU
I would like want a proper
dedicated like soundproofed room
obviously I rent
so I can't do anything like that
but like I don't know
if you know Nene from Kauai
she has like
insane ASMR
it sounds amazing through that microphone
but I just know if I go
that microphone and sound my balls
and open it when the sound is good
yeah you want this and she can
yeah but since 360 degree
honestly
you go for the 2 and the 1
oh no I would never ask for that
I would never ask for that
that's like
I'd rather put that money towards
giving other features
a chance of VLR
put that money towards them
or like
get more success for Gen 1
in the game like there's a project
that's going on for Gen 1
that's coming out soon to you
as I always say soon to you
I would rather put
my money into them
hopefully the 3DO
is good now
almost just creepy
you're not creepy
aren't they like
10,000 USD
with that much money
I could probably get
2 models
and then that's 2 new girls
that get the opportunity
to be a feature
more of their dreams
like as I said I kind of
Gen 1 off collab
I've spoken about it a little bit
I think the key is overrated
I don't know where the 3DO
can sell me
and the Everglot in it can sell
but that's different
I'd be smacking my feet all over
that microphone ability
you can hear me literally step on your face
ASMR
I would make with that key
it would be insane
you can rent a girlfriend
with that money
I thought the coin ring
was like 50 quid
to hire someone for the name
I don't know
but yeah
I feel like I'd rather
work on
than give an opportunity
to a girl
to be the feature of their dreams
I mean to be their dreams
because obviously they get assigned a character
whatever
but in promotional money and stuff
I'm tickling your ears
can you hear the brush
in your ears
all the nitty
bit you there
okay it looks like I'm looking at you
I think it's wonderful
you are the feature of my dreams
I mean
I am allowed to be a little bit selfish
I feel like
if I wanted to get you
I would have been fistin' it myself
I wouldn't ask for that kind of money
for myself
that's too much
maybe
for my one year anniversary
yeah
that sounds like something we could try
for my one year anniversary
I'll spoil us
and I'll buy myself a KU
and then I can put my feet
on it on your face
but
you think I'm joking
and I'm actually gonna do it
I'm gonna be a little selfish
you need to be a little more selfish
sitting on your face
I can do that too
I'll be very gently sitting on that microphone
just let me be clear
I've already done sitting on you
on the 3DO microphone
I'm just waiting for a warning to get off my channel
I'm not gonna be a little real
I thought of an extra about any
two more expense
smaller than the quality
between the next four
and any lively jail or small
hundred
called the chance to play on a 5,020
difference this was small
my friends couldn't know
I will say no
or to play
3DO is more 3DO
is more peak difference
peak
we need to buy mommy a sacrificial microphone
to destroy oh no no
that's already on the way
you see I'm
diabolical enough
that I ordered a microphone
that's going spelunking
well I ordered two
I ordered one microphone to go spelunking
and then I ordered a different
like the same kind of microphone
whilst
that one goes
slimy I guess
I'm gonna go for the slime
I have no idea
what those audios are gonna sound like
but we'll find it together
okay
absolutely zero
clue what it's gonna sound like
but we can do it together
hehe
yeah I'll be fine
I'll explode
one crisp plunking
one other place
slime for you
okay yeah good
this is ice cream
it's pretty good
thank you so much
thank you for the extended membership as well
thank you
surely that's what you're saying
but yes
you will be eating very good
as I say my favorite phrase
is slimy cake because it takes time
for this periphery
some of those
poses were wild
brah when I looked down
I was like I'm literally
glistening down there
I was like what is these poses
does that make your pizza
that's easy
glistening here with sweat
I had sweat on me like
pizza of sweat
that was like I went down
brightness A is my version too
I wonder what it would sound like
maybe I should call it that
like brightness A is more
but I'm trying to hope because this is where
you would be in theory
sweat jar sales
we do fish bras around here
we do couple fish bras
that you don't have anymore
a week on
but you're approaching
to hear the
crunching of the ball
I always say it sounds like thunder
a little bit
sweatshirt
I had some of that
playing Mario Galaxy
wasn't mayors day playing
Mario Galaxy
she had so much fun on it
it looked really good
that painting over with that spine
that came out of nowhere
I was like excuse me
because this came to want
I'm like crunching a little
a little bit of cotton
next to your ear I don't know if you can hear
strongy sweat moistures
you can shy jar in some of the books
click and
prove that all of where
is what we call it
I know you can hear that
that's my little finger
but yeah for 25K
we're doing the
VENKA boss ASMR
VENKA VENKA VENKA
you look like a benzer
she had more color
I'm a very cool cool
I got all the glory
we were already
yeah but can you do this
or this
be minimal taste after streaming
go follow a puppy caller on
what do you want to do to marry Flynn
little puppy day
do you want me to whack my little tail
shake my butt
are you going to call me
your good girl again
your good little pup
oh I'm a sweet dog
whoopsie he's ever gone bad
can't help but cry
it
when your dumb puppy girl
doesn't know what's going on
are we satisfied
with our celebratory
ASMR
gonna be sheepster
set speak roll over
probably the first work I was
like on the floor I'm like
okay
oh wait hold on a minute
I'm gonna be able to redirect you to Islam
I think I should
okay
hold on a minute
no
oh that's what I am
I thought I could read her in the
thank you very much
I think Emmy streams for sheepsters
for those of you who are a member
and do have a stream
I'm gonna be watching
she's done an apartment tour
oh my god Emmy's done her 30k celebration
today right
did you break your heart rate record
I'm freaking broke
okay Emmy's also
doing the celebration today that's fantastic
can I hear
please suck it
she's 900k away from 50
yeah that's cause Emmy's a legend
I always get
I get questions like that
when I upload an ASMR milestone
they're like 5,000
but you're already at the
I'm trying to catch up please
please I'm trying to catch up so hard
yeah my
I think plusoid is broken
the witches aren't working on plusoid
yeah
Emmy's done that
I think I'm so bright
mommy will never catch up to the camera
or say well
I'm trying to find the dead key
which are for me
and then I will
cause I just need to record and write
what I wanna do
and then get to write
say mommy are we keeping the vote up
I'm gonna keep it up
was it really that bad
wait am I going crazy was the vote really that bad
I thought I did okay
should I private it
after stream and then public it
again
when my warning's off
it was pretty good
I mean I like that
I don't think it was that bad
so
because it was a work entry
press X to do
I did not get to do that
please
really legend
okay
thank you for making sure it's all safe
they better not break my streak
or I'm gonna be upset
he's became
the
it's weird how fast Emmy's growing
you're about to pass her
no I don't wanna pass her
I want her to be a hit
I wanna be the most subscribed
I assure you Emmy's been
fantastic with her shorts
Emmy's been fantastic with her shorts
I'm about to help her make some more
and I'm like go Emmy go
go Emmy go
I'm like fucking Emmy
imagine if Emmy gets a play button
not even six months in
that would be crazy
she'd be so proud
shorts as well and I'm so so proud
I'm so proud
I feel like a mummy
thank you for your playing
I love you
I love our children
I love our children together
please give me more babies
I love our children
I'm very happy
oh my god what AC was in our reaction
video stop
no wait hold on
I'm gonna write down that name so I can look after it
look at it after stream
I didn't know my wee baby was in the stream
oh my god the girls are getting
reacted to our babies are growing
I love our baby
baby
thank you everyone for supporting me
and indirectly supporting my babies too
okay now if you don't mind
I'm gonna redirect
to Emmy who is streaming
in two and a half hours okay
I'm gonna prepare for a membership stream
okay
thank you for the really fun day
make sure
how many work hours did we do
I can't remember was it five
or did we do six
I can't remember
40 claps
you want 40 kisses
I can't really guess
the same in the microphone just
YouTube weird
I can blow you though
you
absolutely
I'm gonna rest for 20 minutes
and then we'll watch some of the movie
okay thank you so so much
reflex and thank you everyone
for joining us and subscribers
I'm so excited to do 25k celebration
when the end
and I hope to see you soon
please enjoy Emmy she's up next
please subscribe
love you bye bye
thank you for working out with me
bye bye